we mentioned before that YouTube can be
a great platform to host videos as part
of your content marketing now YouTube
can also be a great place for paid
marketing it's still a young advertising
place so you may find cheaper rates than
you would on let's say AdWords there are
a ton of different ad formats on youtube
and at least four videos you only have
to pay for the ads that people actually
engage with so if someone skips your ad
you don't have to pay a sin now on the
other hand creating a high quality video
and hosting it for free on YouTube can
generate buzz around your product or
service and if you promote it on social
media you can encourage virality now if
you're considering advertising on
YouTube with videos remember that the
viewers attention span can be pretty
short so you want to invest a high
quality video that can hook your users
really quickly so let's explore just a
couple of the different formats you can
use on YouTube because there are a ton
of options available to you check out
the link in the instructor notes if you
want to see all of them one option is
the desktop or mobile video mastheads
these are video ads that play on YouTube
homepage on a desktop they play without
any sound and it'll end as a thumbnail
of your video or any other video from
your channel on mobile the video
thumbnails will be available for your
users to click on you can even add a
link directly to your website let's look
at what those look like so here's the
video masthead you can also have a rich
medium masthead which would go here as
well so the rich media mastheads are
seen in that same location you can do a
ton with the custom mastheads from
carousels use cool videos or just images
there's a lot of options out there I'm
surprising I know but you can also have
a video ad I'm sure you've noticed these
ads playing before different videos that
you've seen on YouTube now there are
different options for the video ads not
skippable in-stream video ads our videos
that appear prima doorpost role when
viewing different content on YouTube
they could be around 15 to 30 seconds
long and the viewer must watch the
entire ad before they're able to watch
their selected video now for the
skippable ads you can go to the true
view format and there are a few
different types of TrueView ads so you
have the in-stream that play before a
video and you're allowed to skip after 5
seconds you could have display ads that
are
our suggested videos in that suggested
video list let's check that out here's
an example of a display ad and this is
an example of an in-stream overlay ad
and there are a few more options for
TrueView ads you can check the link in
the instructor notes for more so you can
have your standard display ads which are
similar to what you just saw and you
also saw the in video overlay ads they
pop up and you can select them while
you're watching a video or you had the
option of closing them but as I said
before there are ton of different ad
options in YouTube you can even do live
streaming ads if you'd like so check out
the documentation to learn more